[Music]
a pair of twins that was separated at
birth one raised in the u.s and one
raised in korea ended up with a massive
iq difference oh wow
guess which one's which one's in korea
one's in the us yeah korean smarter part
of the us
is the one from america on only fans
big titties lots of drama
uh love chanel dude what if this is
flipped and you're just like
another one in korea crazy plastic
surgery super fine
only found like all the other koreans
what in america her favorite line to ask
guys is why didn't you call me back
sorry women i'm sorry that's her
yearbook quote for her senior picture
why didn't you call me back
joe
the other the other girls are like a
socrates line
yeah so the um
is that what you guys are saying do you
think the one in korea is smarter yeah
probably yeah why would that be the case
uh just probably just a better education
stereotypes because they can hit their
kids in korea yeah
honestly they have better grades there
than the brain cells yeah yeah that's
like man callus is the brain yeah right
they have less opportunity so they have
to work really hard to get good grades
so they could get hired by hyundai
there's only three companies that they
can work for lotte hyundai and samsung
probably yeah the work ethic just the
culture over there is is different than
here i think mm-hmm yeah yeah so the
weird thing is that uh the iq difference
between the two is 16
points about iq values but 16 is a lot
10's a lot i mean uh
i mean i'm saying 16 is a lot but i
think every five is a lot yeah yeah
i would know earlier
remember earlier when i said jcla this
is what this is what happens over here
yeah they said alumni
they've never even measured an iq
difference between twins that was more
than seven points whoa so genetically
i'll kind of give it to you they say
that genetically it's supposed to be
pretty similar um it's supposed to be
and it's never deviated higher than
seven so was the american girl raised on
walmart that is depressing yeah well my
question also is were they both adopted
or just one was sent to be adopted
because that happened how far yeah how
[ __ ] is that though oh we know someone
like that we do just the twin got sent
off yeah because they don't have enough
money for two that's kind of sad but
also like super [ __ ] imagine being
sent off physically had a lot of issues
um the medical care so they send up the
other one to be adopted and then he got
adopted my white family and you know
brought up i think
yeah i think they they were not both
adopted i think one just one
so it could be
so now this could be that the america
the one in america was deficient because
maybe something was wrong with her
medically or physically he sent her away
that could that could be a possibility
but let's say all things being equal
i'm gonna vote that the smarter one is
in korea yeah i would too okay you guys
are right the smarter one is in korea
why is it not that surprising do we have
pictures the one that's fine right here
yeah what are those pictures look like
you can't find any picture where they
you can do when you they're like babies
in these photos but i mean now they're
like 40 years old oh they're 40 yeah
way they're only fantastic i'm sorry
korean women and i'm sorry old women i
just you know i mean sorry about korean
women still look 25.
i mean i'm not gonna lie hey if a 40
year old like me man i'd be thrilled
dude
yeah i feel like korean women are like
until 49 they look like they're 25 and
on their 50th birthday they turn 80.
yeah
so it's a lot of asians though here's
here's the story as to why they believe
the uh american girl has a lower iq
the twin who was raised in korea grew up
in a happy harmonious home
the us-based twin had a turbulent
childhood where she lost her family
found a new one and then those that
family got divorced oh my god okay well
then yeah there's also the american uh
shouldn't be laughing [ __ ] the american
girl got three concussions throughout
her life oh my god doing what
soccer taekwondo with the board to the
head
from family to family
did she stand in the way of her dad's
hand or like
yeah she had a she had a problem of
interfering with mid haymaker seriously
yeah well concussions would probably do
that to you i was like that's this is
not all things equal
they did they did it says they scored
identical for self-esteem and mental
health that's cool but in terms of like
cognitive ability for like you know like
problem solving sure yeah so she's a
happy dummy she's just
i'd settle with being happy don't have
to breathe after three concussions right
so then really nothing could be wrong
yeah concussion because that's actually
yeah that's just a [ __ ] mind reset
man
yeah it is that's pretty hard especially
okay and i don't mean to sound sexist
yeah but for a female to go through a
concussion that's that's huge physical
trauma where she's not used to unless
she's a soccer player but like that's
not something they're normally like used
to like guys if we fight you get hit
we're allowed a few yeah some full
contact yeah like you get used to
getting hit and then then when you get
the concussion here you're like okay
cool but you got to get hit really hard
after christmas i don't think i ever had
a concussion only i've ever had a
concussion but your head is shaped
pretty crazy i feel it but it's like
it's like meant to take damage that
would be pretty embarrassing to be
reunited with your twin and then you
take a high q test and you're just that
much lower
what if you're a lot happier
yeah just saying
i met a lot of really smart sad people
they're the same i'm the happiness meter
yeah whatever imagine taking the actual
test right you're like hmm and they're
twins like done they're just walking out
and they're like [ __ ] i was only halfway
through
literally the happiness test was first
oh yeah
yeah because then like what if the
happiness test was like that was before
they revealed the scores of the iq to
them yeah well what's weird though is
like imagine being a twin and you know
you're reunited and it's great like if
you're reunited with your long lost
brother or sister that you're not a twin
no one gives you tests
but then you're twins oh well let's take
these tests you know
let's do this experiment
you would say versus korea
like what why are you putting lines on
twins like why are you putting wires all
over me who put this article out is it
the country of korea america did
like america the country put it in
america the country
as opposed to america the community
it's technically from lab bible so that
means it's an it's a independent it's uh
australia
oh it's australian well if it's lad
bible that's it that's what they're
saying isn't it
steaks
or british yeah it's neither
australian wagon is fake as food it's
delicious though my life is fake i mean
real wagyu is the way that they treat
the
the cow they
get it drunk every day that's real wagyu
and it's also now supposed to now
they're
doing quibbling over the line the
hereditary line or the cow yeah oh i
smell it yeah so like apparently when
you buy like wagyu it'll tell you their
genetic makeup like they're their la the
line of what cows they give you a 23 and
me
of your cow that's like so bizarre do
you remember when they were able it
wasn't um everyone was saying that it
was kobe beef for at everything yeah
yeah yeah place ever and then they
stopped doing that it's not that special
anymore well because you also it's also
like totally not believable yeah like
really there's that mini curly beef you
can serve it at the dallas stadium to
everyone there
at each burger stand in the stadium it
was like everything's curly beef like no
way there's that many cows what's weird
bizarre with kobe is is that they'll
have kobe burgers but you know before
kobe in america new york steak was
considered like a dope cut or like filet
mignon but we never had filet mignon or
new york steak burgers yeah but all of a
sudden kobe there's kobe burgers
what happened like i don't get like we
never we never i think you get a taste
of kobe instead of paying 100 bucks you
get a taste of 20 bucks
but we never like thought to like you
know bastardize a new york steak to turn
into a burger well cause it doesn't
sound exotic they're steaks and make
them into burgers [ __ ] steaks
even even the worst part of a kobe cow
is better than the best part of an
american probably
wasn't kobe named after kobe japan yeah
kobe's an area
after the steak i think was it from the
steak they saw i think the dad was like
this is the best thing i want my son to
be the best it was it wasn't their their
fabulous tv chips that they made for
giant screen tvs
because remember when kobe had that
earthquake
yeah and then uh there was a tv shortage
because that's we had a lot of factories
there yeah it was a tv shortage yeah at
that time it was i think it was like in
the 90s yeah oh so during like the sony
vega era yeah
yeah
when that was like the hot item yeah
this is like when it was two tvs it was
like before like dlp and flat screens
but like most of the chips were made in
kobe japan wow along with the cows
there was a there was another thing
something happened i think like five
years ago it was another earthquake
maybe it was fukushima probably
fukushima but nikon
had their factory there and nikon was
going to release this
camera that was specific like for
landscape um photographers
phenomenal camera but because that
earthquake happened it shut down the
factory nikon just scrapped the plans
for it
and a lot of people were like what the
hell remember that like we were waiting
for this particular and they had two
versions one for landscape and one for
like portrait regular photography
and it was like made just for these
lenses wow and i was like oh this is
dope and then
now the world would never see it yeah
never see it they're they had prototypes
made people touched it they took photos
with it and they were we're waiting for
mass production but
oh never come back out with it no i
don't know your people are so prideful
dude oh man
i don't know why they're like that oh
the earthquake that means no no camera
forget it
that was a good japanese accent
it's like it was a real samurai huh
you